the podcasting industry is booming but
among the true crime comedy and current
affairs we found hours of anti-semitic
racist and white supremacist material on
one of the most popular platforms
spotify most of the content we found is
just too explicit to feature here one
episode promotes holocaust denial in
others we hear dehumanizing language
about people of color and talk of
biological superiority
in one episode a man promotes a
far-right anti-semitic conspiracy theory
and calls for violence against jewish
people for nine minutes
what it feels like it's just doing is
really normalizing this sort of work if
you can
you know go on spotify and you can
listen to adele and then you can listen
to this stuff right next to it you know
that that that really is that really is
bad news
these two series amount to nearly 80
hours of content and it's just some of
what we found there's more out there
we took our findings to hannah kirk who
ran transcripts of the podcast through
an ai hate speech detection model the
results were decisive this is stuff that
is not hard to find
as we go down yep so more slurs this
time racial slurs so we've kind of had
the
full host of
homophobic slurs racist slurs disability
slurs
um
yeah i mean there's this isn't really
being hidden in any way it's
very clear
and it is clear in many of the podcasts
we looked at this one was displaying
imagery adopted by white supremacists
another gave a link to its telegram
channel where they don't exactly hide
their beliefs the fact that this content
is readily accessible really is a cause
for concern
because what that means is not only can
really hardened hateful extremists
get what they want but it also means
that people who are just simply trying
to find answers might stumble across
this content which then pushes them in
the direction of hatred down this rabbit
hole where they too might be radicalized
spotify says it does not allow hate it
removed nearly 150 hours of content
after we've reported it during our
investigation hana says that new
technology that could make content
moderation on audio platforms easier is
on the horizon
but unless podcasting giants like
spotify are determined to stamp out hate
it's likely to keep appearing
victoria elms sky news